أبناء المهيب صدام حسين،
قاتلوا المحتل كالأسود،
لم يهِنوا ولم يستكينوا، حتى نالوا الشهادة،
عدي وقصي صدام حسين،
وحفيد صدام مصطفى قصي،
ثلاثة قاوموا فرقة أمريكية بأكملها،
حاصرهم الأمريكان في منزل،
وأمطروهم بالرصاص لكن لم يستطيعوا قتلهم،
قصف مدفعي وضربات بالطائرات،
ما هذه الشجاعة؟ وكيف كانت نهاية ابني صدام وحفيده؟
(لمعرفة بقية تفاصيل الحادثة للقصة بقية)
عندما ترك صدام بغداد ذهب معه ابناه
عدي وقصي وحفيده مصطفى
في أبريل 2003، كانت الدبابات الأميركية في وسط المدينة،
واصلوا مقاومة القوات الأميركية والبريطانية.
وتولى حينها عدي قيادة فرقة "فدائيو صدام"
(الموالية للرئيس العراقي، كما كان مخططاً له مسبقا)
". ولجأ الأخان عدي وقصي والحفيد مصطفى
إلى شخص يدعى نواف الزيدان
( الذي قيل إنه كانت تربطه بعائلة صدام علاقة عشائرية)
وظلوا هناك  متخفّين عن الأنظار،
وكان ذلك بعد عودة ابني صدام من الأراضي السورية
التي توجها إليها بعد دخول القوات الأميركية
في مارس عام 2003،،، ،
وفي صباح يوم 23 يوليو 2003
شنت قوات التحالف بقيادة القوات الأمريكية
عملية عسكرية على مخبئهما في مدينة الموصل حي البريد
في معركة دامت لأكثر من 6 ساعات ،،
،بعد تلقي وشاية عنهما، وحصول من وشى بهما على المكافأة
البالغة 25 مليون دولار المعلنة قبل الهجوم،
وكان الشخص الخائن الذي قام  بالإبلاغ عن مكانهم
يدعى" نواف محمد الزيدان،،  ...
وبينما ابنا صدام وحفيده يختبؤون في ذلك المنزل،
إذ بهم يسمعون مكبرات الصوت تصيح بهم
أن سلموا أنفسكم فالمنزل محاصر برا وجوا،
ليس لكم ملاذ إلا أن تسلموا أنفسكم أو أن تقتلوا بنيراننا
حتى لو اضطررنا أن ندك المنزل فوق رؤوسكم،،
استل ابنا صدام كل ما وجد معهما من أسلحة وذخيرة،
والحفيد الصغير مندهش مما يجري،
تمركزوا في أماكن محصنة، وإذ بقذائف المدافع تتهافت عليهم
من كل الاتجاهات،
صوبوا أسلحتهم نحو قوات الاحتلال وبدأوا الاشتباك،
أسقطوا جنديين أو ثلاثة، فذعر المحتلون،
عندها ضربة مفاجئة للطيران تحدث فجوة في المنزل
لكن أبطال صدام لم يخافوا،
واستغلوا ارتباك الجنود إثر الضربة التي كان يفترض أن يرتبكوا هم منها،
وعادوا لمواصلة استمتاعهم بأنفاسهم الأخيرة
لكن بإسقاط جنود المارينز واحدا تلو الآخر، ..
نعم فنحن لسنا في مسلسل تلفزيوني بل قصة حقيقية لبطلي صدام،،،
قاوم فيها  الأبطال هنا حتى ازداد القصف المدفعي
وأمطرهم المارينز بالنيران ،،،
هنا وفي هذه اللحظات سقط ابنا صدام قصي وعدي شهيدين في أرض المنزل.....
عندها قامت الفرقة 101 المحمولة جواً و معها 200 من الجنود
بتضييق الخناق على المنزل الذي لم يبقى فيه إلا طفل
لم يبلغ الرابعة عشرة من عمره،،،
فما الذي سيفعله هذا الطفل؟، ،،،،،
عندما رأى  الطفل مصطفى _ نجل قُصي صدام حسين
أباه وعمه قد استشهدا لم يبكي وينتظر قدره كأي طفل ،
بل اختار موقعاً محصناً وأخذ بندقيته، وقام بالمقاومة ،
حاول جنود المارينز الدخول للمنزل بعدما قتلوا ابني صدام،
لكن مصطفى الصبي الصغير صوب كل من اقترب
حتى أسقط ١٥ جنديا من المارينز...
ما هذه الشجاعة؟!
ومن أين تأتي هذه الطلقات؟
هل هناك قناص في المنزل؟
تساءل جنود المارينز والخوف يدب في قلوبهم.....
وبعد أن عجزت القوات الأمريكية باقتحام المنزل
حينها قررت القوات قصف المنزل بالكامل
و سقط الصبي مصطفى شهيدا بجانب أبيه وعمه،،
فكيف له أن يعيش وقد رأى تلك المشاهد المروعة،،، ...
ودفن عُدي في قرية العوجة بجانب أخيه قصي و((ابن قصي))
مصطفى وعمه برزان إبراهيم الحسن والرئيس السابق لمحكمة الثورة عواد البندر
وفي 24 يوليو 2003 عرضت جثتهما على الصحفيين في مطار بغداد الدولي
بعد خضوعها لعملية ترميم لكي يشبها ما كانا عليه اثناء حياتهما قدر الإمكان".
واظهرت الصور التي تم توزيعها وجهيهما وقد غطيا بالدماء وآثار إصابات متعددة.
وقالت بعض المنظمات الدولية إنه تم قتلهم بواسطة أسلحة محرمة دولية
قبل استهدافهم بغارة، وقامت القوات الأمريكية بهدم المنزل بالكامل
ورفع الأنقاض عنه وتبديل التراب فيه حتى لا تنكشف أسلحتهم المحرمة دولياً،
وما زال حتى الآن البيت قطعة ارض فقط وهو موجود في حي يدعى الفلاح
على شارع الشلالات...
عندما يموت البطل تبقى قصته خالدة إلى الأبد،
كما هم أبناء صدام وحفيده،،  فقد سطروا بطولات تاريخية ضد المحتل
برغم تخلي الكثير من الجنود عنهم،
فأبهروا العالم ببطولاتهم وهم يصارعون الموت
بعد خيانة أحد المقربين.....